es otro revés judicial para jimmy lai el
célebre magnate de la prensa hong kong
es a ha sido declarado culpable por
participar e incitar la participación en
la vigilia del pasado año para
recordarte anam en ese acto
multitudinario con miles de velas
encendidas en el parque victoria forma
parte ya de la identidad hongkonesa por
el gobierno lo ha prohibido en las dos
últimas ediciones por las restricciones
al movimiento dictadas por el
coronavirus junto a jimmy la hayan sido
condenadas otras dos grandes figuras del
movimiento la abogada johan tum y la
periodista gwyneth y los tres son los
únicos que se habían declarado inocentes
de los cargos otros 16 activistas habían
sido condenados con anterioridad tras
haber aceptado los hechos la ley de
seguridad nacional cocinada por pekín y
enviada a hong kong ha sido un desastre
para el movimiento antigubernamental y
en especial para jimmy lai la presión
judicial le obligó a cerrar el apple
daily un diario popular que lideraba la
lucha contra pekín y en la cárcel espera
el largo listado de pleitos pendientes
esa ley divide a los con con heces para
unos
acabado con el marco de libertades para
otros en cambio devolvió la paz a la
isla después de un año de disturbios
sociales